when you go out and tell new countries
no I'm sorry I I know we got rich with
fossil fuels and that was really cool
for us but you can't do it you can't uh
develop this way you have to use solar
and wind now if solar and wind was so
great that they're actually cheaper
which of course a lot of people will
claim then it might make sense but then
you wouldn't have to tell the people
because they would just do it because it
was cheaper but of course that's not
actually true that's why we have to
subsidize him here that's why we have to
push him onto more people fundamentally
Sol and wind is cheaper maybe when the
sun is shining and the wind is blowing
but when it's not it's infinitely
expensive and that's why most people
just have it as a little Boutique addon
in reality most countries will only get
rich if they have lots of power cheaply
available and available 24/7 and that
will typically right now mostly be
fossil fuel